here's the revised FBI definition of
rape penetration no matter how slight of
the vagina or anus with any part body
part or object or oral penetration by a
sex organ of another person without the
consent of the victim today is what I'm
using for the FBI for the FBI perfect
perfect so again that's the statistic I
want to work with according to your
statistic there is at 90 something
thousand right per year in 2015
doing the math for that you because you
wanted to say over a lifetime we agree
over a lifetime
that would require 1,600 years 15 to 16
hundred years or so for it to be one in
five women raped in a lifetime so the
FBI statistics would reflect actually
much more severely what I'm talking
about from the Bureau of Justice I want
to go by that definition I agree on that
definition of rape I do not agree on the
CDC definition where anyone experiences
claims that they experience rape I think
the FBI is more accurate because we just
defined it can we agree but you haven't
given me a different definition from the
CDC no you I just use your own FBI
statistic which more which is more valid
because it was defines deep Stephen
you're saying you agree with that
definition but you don't agree with the
CDC definition but you haven't provided
me there is no definition the burden is
on you to provide the definition if
you're saying there's a rape culture
there is no definition from the CDC it's
regretful wait for me to look up this
entire survey the National intimate
partner Michael that you might do that
or not Michael here's my point the the
FBI statistics and the Bureau of Justice
Statistics either official statistics of
where you can verify rate is also
official to government and it's not it's
not official if it's a poll but the
policy the CDC isn't official okay
what's more accurate a pole or the votes
in an election what the point is you're
quoting a poll I am quoting actually a
survey a survey as a poll no it's not a
poll Steven well I guess you're right
that is a survey the survey is a poll so
my point is if we are going to go out
and throw out the allegation which by
the way can destroy lives of young men
rapists if the lyric beneath the train
train tracks if we're going to throw out
that allegation we need a whole lot more
than a poll
and every single verifiable statistic
including the ones that you've sworn out
today from the FBI prove the idea of 1
in 5 completely totally false no that's
just not true
now if we don't you show me the FBI
statistics show that is statistics of
the incidence of reported the word
reported to law enforcement I've seen
various studies that say only thirty to
forty percent are reported you obviously
disagree with that even if that were the
case were eliminating it down to nine
hundred years for it to be one in five I
mean you're going anecdotal going
anecdotal and everyone watching this
knows that not one in five women they
know are raped and you know how I know
my wife right now as we speak
right now as we tape this interview is
at a crisis pregnancy center where she
volunteers she knows these statistics
through and through and she has to
report it when rape occurs this is what
she does this is what the FBI does and
the statistics that you have given us
today when we have defined actual rape
on which we agree the FBI or Bureau of
Justice the CDC is a poll nowhere can
you prove that there is a one in five
chance of rate of one in five incidents
of rape thus there is no systematic rape
culture okay so let's say you're correct
I'll grant you that you are absolutely
100% correct think what is the correct
number of women who are raped over the
course of a lifetime
yeah it's about point zero three and
five six point one per thousand so six
point one per thousand over the course
of a lifetime what are you basing that
on and basing it on the statistics that
you've given me from the FBI and the
Bureau of Justice Statistics that
specifically rate relate to campus so it
tells me to do math which is gonna be
difficult for me ninety thousand like
that in order we have a common law
enforcement in 2015 if we agree that
what half of rapes are reported forty
percent of rapes are reported what do
you think it is let's let's say that I
don't agree but let's say that for the
sake of argument because I want you to
do this math live on air I don't think
it's gonna turn out too well for you I
know but you may you might be right so
let's say it is forty percent or thirty
percent is the number that I most
commonly see that our reporter which
means seventy percent are not reported
so we'd have to triple that number to
about 250 to 300 thousand rapes per year
now
in any society that I can think of that
seems like a lot of rapes per year yes
but it's not one in five so it's well
it's 300,000 per year now over the
course of a lifetime from let's say age
12 to age what 70 which is why but first
off you have your cut-offs our ageist as
though no one wants to rape anybody over
70 years old I think that's wildly 12 in
1754 between 18 and 34 28 percent
between 35 and 60 43% age 65 plus no
Michael you said we were getting off in
the weeds earlier would it stand to
reason that we're more often the weeds
now that because of the statistics you
presented you're doing math based on
assumptions that you can't verify we're
making estimations when I have just
agreed that 300,000 is probably a
reasonable number of rapes that occur to
women no no we didn't hear no we didn't
I said I'll give it to you for this case
for you to be able to do your math is
what I said I said yes not wanted is
much lower
it's yes much more than one in five it's
still much lower than one inside so with
the math 600 years explain that to me
because three hundred thousand one
hundred and sixty eight which was then
which is the rough range of years that
I'm giving you okay do the math right
now three hundred thousand times 58 is
seventeen million right I agree with
that number okay so let's get back can
we we agree that that we got off in the
weeds I would I would say that I was
correct regarding the statistics let's
say we're not but can we agree that
there's certainly the burden of proof on
someone who is claiming a rape culture
to prove so it's a shocking statistic
and it can't be beyond a poll which
doesn't define rape and so that's it
does define rape you and I don't have
the definition in front of us clearly it
must or else it couldn't it wouldn't be
a survey but well again if it falls
under that the definition is the
California statute of affirmative
consent that is any regretful sex we
don't know what
falls under there's no reason to think
it would fall into the California sand
saying that it's in national service
it's a national survey but of course
would have to allow for that umbrella
considering that certain states would
consider that rape we don't know you and
I don't know it's a poll Michael let's
say that it's a poll which is very
melodic on as evidence as the same as
reports and incidents from a Federal
Bureau of Investigation the FBI from the
Bureau of Justice survey from the FBI is
also a poll according to your definition
no numbers from the different states
which report no it's not Michael yes it
is that's how they get it they get it
from incidents of rape that actually are
reported criminally yeah from each state
yes would we not agree that that is
probably even if you say only 40 percent
of rapes as we gave you even if you say
only 40 percent of rapes but I don't
agree to but I'm giving to you for the
sake of argument I'm saying that's a
very high estimate of the numbers okay
not if you consider people like Lena
Dunham who come out and claim rape and
then we find out that it's verifiably
false but let's assume 40 percent of
rapes from that you haven't any evidence
that's verifiably false what you're
doing is you're denying her first off I
believe I believe in a system of law
that was my original intention writing
holy SH the video because what you're
doing is you're denying something that
she experienced and you have no idea
what the burden of proof is on her when
she's making an allegation of crime she
did not she made an allegation of who
says she was raped she didn't make an
allegation of crime as you as I was
raped is that not a crime of course it
is then she accused someone who she
named Barry about national treasury of
Treasury of the College Republicans
where she was
we were easily able to find a time frame
that person was easily able to be found
and we were eby's easily able to trace
it back and see if that incident had
occurred and she afterward walked it
back but it is a crime to say it was to
accuse someone of a crime and she said
the person who people found wasn't the
person that she said I'll quote I'll
quote to you upload her to you Michael
you said she didn't accuse anyone of a
crime saying I was raped did someone
commit a crime she did not specifically
name the person Michael pseudonym okay
just
is that an accusation of crime being
committed Michael for someone who wants
to use a pole as data is someone saying
I'm raped it's a very simple question if
I say I'm raped was a crime committed am
I making a claim of a crime yes you are
okay between making a claim of a crime
and accusing somebody of a crime okay
let's go with that let's say it's a
claim of a crime because that would
still be filed under that pole I am
saying and this is important because I
think you're little you might have a
blind spot here just as far as being a
little bit out of touch with what people
see as rape people would even read lena
Dunham's own story most people did when
she accused she made the claim let's say
she made the claim of a crime being
committed people have read her own story
and said that shouldn't be lumped in the
same category with the actual rapes that
are reported that you cited now were
then taking claims like lena Dunham's
very loose claims regretful sex sex
under and the influence of alcohol
putting that under the umbrella of rape
to create a false one-in-five statistic
to go out and claim a rape culture as my
point you're conflating her experience
with the CDC's statistic in you and I
just oh we believe that she would not be
included in the CDC statistic of rape
when she says she lies she claims she
was raped flat out and we're saying that
the CDC would not include her when they
include people who claim experiencing
rape I suppose they would yes they would
in my point is that would of course
inflate a statistic that would be
completely and totally irreconcilable
with the actual statistics that we have
from the FBI in the Bureau of Justice so
let's say that the actual claim is what
the actual number of women who are raped
and we're only talking about rape now
we're not talking about sexual
intimidation we're not talking about
sexual harassment we're not talking
about stalking we're not talking about
grabbing by the [ __ ] or by whatever it
is we're only talking about rape yeah at
that number yes is what one in twenty
know I gave you the number it's about
6.1 in 1,000 you haven't given me any
basis for that number other than we're
gonna keep on this until we're blue in
the face a right let's go with the poll
that includes Lena Dunham because she
found a condom in a plant
Michael's the point is he is a
government Michael the point is they
keep changing you can even the goal
peace justice the study that you said it
has only to do with college no no
Michael I'm also using the FBI
statistics so the reason I'm leaving
hundred thousand per year on total okay
Michael I need you to understand that
I'm giving you a gift here okay and let
me explain how the a gives you give me
thank you very much and I appreciate you
coming on the show and I genuinely am a
fan of a lot of the work that you've
done so I wish this could have been more
amicable I am using your statistics the
FBI statistics which are very
unforgiving to your stance okay in using
the Bureau of Justice Statistics which
would actually be more lenient on
definitions of rape because it would go
by college reporting's of rape not even
F beat not even federal reporting's or
criminal reporting's of rape but girls
on college campus who report rape that
would be who it could be to a governing
student body not just a not just a Brent
to the United States government or state
government again that statistic would be
more generous to your argument than the
FBI statistic and it still is nowhere
close to one in five
we have no statistical evidence
whatsoever outside of one poll from the
CDC which isn't defined which includes
definitions of rape which most Americans
agree aren't rape to prove that we have
a rape culture and so my point is when I
go out and I make a video setting these
exact statistics about rape culture and
you respond wholly it's appalling the
burden on you is to prove it I don't
believe you've done that effectively
today if you like this video subscribe
by clicking the button that says
subscribe if you're not aware of it now
there's no way you're learning the
Internet at this point I'm not going to
help you but this was clipped from my
daily show available exclusively to
lotto with credit com / mug club members
of your student military or veteran
internet promo code it's less than six
dollars a month and you get daily
content no more clips Plus this hand at
smug oh I just when I feel it I got a
chill like on the inside